[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちはん
ただご紹介にあずかりましたジョージ大学総合グローバル学部3年の雪よろしくと申し
ます
今日はスタンダードとさんが来るリアクションというテーマで皆さんにお話をさせて
いただきたいと思います
いつもがこの世の中にもっともっと面白い暗礁が薄れているようなプロジェクトだって
みんなそれぞれが色んなことをがんばっているようなせない
何から今孫たちができる可能性会を合同面白い事になるんじゃないかなって思って生活
しています
まあいきなりこんなガキなことを言ってお前は誰やと思った方もいるんじゃないかなと
思いますので簡単に僕と持ちご紹介をさせていただきたいと思います
動くこれまで本当にいろんな釣り首をやってみました
ん
後方知念に5足以上
ネパールという風にね
監修取り込みネパールの中でも山奥にある電気も水もないようなグラデ
やつをしていたり
ここに愛する時はば彼氏で現地に線の大学生と一緒に脚光戦争プロジェクトたされ
第すればな彼らはネパール日本の学生の右足を作ろうと思って
学生名所の
サービスは7回今まで作詞作100人以上の問題で何か
他にも50回色々な
ですかいい
昨年の参議院選挙では僕
お世話になってる先生の選挙用絶賛にが詰まって
そしたら完全にインスパイアされているように始まった
hello world
あそんなこともありながら今バーいろんなことやってるんですけど
+最後に政治家柄も少しやってきて
日本ではステージに考える
というか25歳なんですけど非正規店年齢を20歳ルカ21歳
作業っていうような活動もしてます
全部でも本当にこれまでいろんな活動をしてきて
からでも将来ともいうか
ているだろうなと言う
ただ
この全てのプロジェクトがこれ以外にも本当に実際
たくさん
行ってきました取り組みを通じているのがあるん
良い車台を作り卓球
ことですね
中にこれは彼だけじゃなくて頂
皆さんそういう子はすべての弟すべての皆さんが同じことを
いいんじゃないかなと
ただ日報で
こんなことを許しません
何かするんだいお話じゃないのかなっ
社会のために自分も何かできることをしたいだけをも実際にアクションと思うんです
けどハードルが高いし
ついて中のかわからない
僕の友達がよく相談を受けます
今後実際ちょっとあまりわからないところではあるんですが今日は
皆さんにどうやったらアクションを起こせるようになるのかということを話したいと
思うんですよ私で
を言葉にしておきたいのがこれまでいろんなことやって来ておりました
ただそのどれも世界を変えるような大きなプロジェクトだったり
スイッチ増やすようだから100件でもなんでもありません
は誰でもです
ことをやったらじゃないんです
7今日皆さんに世界を変えるような部屋の造りであるとその息子と話せないけど
ちょっとハードルを下げてもらってどうやったら自分の中にある重いよう行動6つ
ができるのかなという話をさせてもらえばいい
この写真どこだかわかりません
人ばかり見ず0これ超地帯のウィークリー今日れる場所で長文のホール photo
今日言われてあげてした
上智大学の学生から毎日この
これよボールんですけど
今年ある昨日
比例日の写真声
なんではちょっとわかりにくいと思うんですか
これを作成したのは昨年1月ばもとても大地震の翌日の写真です
の鉄芯が乗って北東北なまりかの形で
もないん
まあというのはいますが古いものじゃないじゃあ
金貨作るから中間やってみろということで
地震が発生翌日から4日間毎日を開く日の1時間だけ
募金活動ということにしましたら
大変大きい立つやったことあるわかるんですけど
体の切手をダイハツ学んだよ
1日だったけど3枚の3枚くらいしか使わない
だけどやっぱりこの子のために力があることができないよじゃない
どうやったらほんと多くの餅を集められるなんて考えてくれ
じゃあ金活動でも本当にうまく育つが多くの人に知ってもらえるんじゃないかなって
ポップン僕が常に考えは者9人の大学生を
このメインストリート量は金100円ぐらいあるんですけどザーッとナマズで一斉に
募金活動をする
するとジョージ大学の学生だったら絶対にこの僕の小さい
必要な簡単と違いなかった
そこを通るたびにお願いしまーすシャクってくれるわけですから
絶対の汽車の
するしかないラン打ったらまずて遠回りして帰ったらまずそれでも
ok たった4時間きっかりそうです
それでも14万円の募金が集まったんですよね
金活動でまさに誰でもで重要なことですよね
多分そこをちゃんとした場合のステップあるだけで
もともと分頃の自分の起こしたアクションが持っている完成したことができる
かもしれん
っていうことを考えた時にこの募金活動が当たったを作りで考えていたんですけど
どんなことでもと同じちゃうと日誰にでもできることでいいから
自分の想い
もしかしたらたければ自分なのでずっと大きなインパクト社会に与えることがで十分
面白い
ということの問題ません
てい
そう考えから
アクション物っていうのは全然ハードルが高いことでもなんでもなくて
誰にでもできることをやればいいということをここはいつも思っています
だ
ありませんすればいいかわからないこれお願いに行ったことない人にとってはもちろん
最初の1頭っていうのは怖いですね
者部門を出している黒子初めて日本でアクションを起こしたらば大一音スレ part
1年間生活
日本に帰国したその超とっ
来れば自分だした経験を多くの人に伝えなきゃいけないと思ってい
二連心の講演会を企画したいです
報国寺の初めての日本でのアクションなったんですけど
1か月以上前に自分でイベントステージをやってきて自分
講演会のチラシを自分で作ってそして商品名スピーチも作ったんですけど
講演会の前日あることに気がついたんです
どうやった彼等から撮影のん
おばあさんとで初めてイベントって収納もしない大トロポイントなってことをしてい
ます
デサート今でもよく覚えていますよりを通じだったから10位だったが4組だして陳情
の中に向かうと思う
遊び帰り道で抑えていただける
逆さで来てくれたんですねというような僕
の失敗例があってはじめての願書ってば本当に良い方がもっと苦い思い出でもあるん
ですけど
初めてですごく覚えと思う
だけど実際になりであるというのは全然ハードルが高くないんだよってことを
今日皆さんにお話できればいいなと思って
まず最初にアクションを起こす手掛けるに何が大事なのかというと社会の声に3行がた
受けるということです
御札もそうなんですけど何かアクションを起こしたい何かやってみたいって思うような
ちょっと安い
の強い人にターンしているという
何しろ何をしようという言葉
なんでどういうアクションのかっていうと思い取るけど全然考えないことがあるんです
だけどシーンの言われる一番大事なのは何をやるかではなく
なぜやるか
鹿鳴館なに付かないそれかというばっか考えてもそういう時って全く言い合いで覚えた
バラ
しかも何が開く3ポスターとしてもそこの思いが詰まってないから誰も尿管を与える
含めていきたい
兄弟を言うこともできないし可能たい持った
だからまずは何ですが蕎麦ん症を起こすのか
いうことを自分の中で明確に理解していなきゃいけないかと
おりましたじゃあそれをどうやってやるのかそんなに難しくない心を持っています
自分の周りでイベントに華をしてみたときに
荒れてない
がおかしいんじゃないと
問題ので
ちょっとヤバいー
そういうような多いのってきたらそれはマッチ
周辺何
そういう思いが出てきたらまずはどんどん行動です
英文でこれが一番もぐらいそして位
産業がすぐのズレ
なんですよん
三国に考えられるもないですよねつまり何か他の思いはを切れてきたらなんでもいい
からくれ
ふうに移している
ということでねー
ニーズデー
考えを考えるとが生まれるんです
ああ
親御4
考えれば考えるほど者の方
いいん
難しい free
天性のもので僕の経験上ほとんどの場合
考え過ぎたらアクションを作ってあげます
っていうことでボクは常にこのことにしています何も考えずまず友達に連絡してみると
学
ちょっと一躍ないそんな9年末の一つアクションを
そしてこれが最
ですがね
しようとかな美味いニャー
ありません
今回ん
このセットのテーマでもあるんですあるんですけど
どんなことでもいいとか思っています
何かの賞持ってるに最初にいきなり世界を変えるなくてやれって言われても無理です
僕の飲んでできない
[音楽]
容量じゃあ躾サティ分
世界に一つたちのアクションになると思って
日本以上小川前日に書いてあるんですけど
僕はんああああ
今はなんか会津のにいろんな会社ができたりとかいろんなと静かでしたいろんなから
するというのなアクションで世界せいでもたくさんできています
誰もがゴンともっと持っていた
もっと持っています
いろんな人が
自分の中の小山心の中にある多いを何かしらの行動に移すことができたらそれを自分
なりのアクションにつなげることができたらこの世の中もっともっとが幼稚園に外れて
も白い社会になるんじゃないかなって言う
ています
僕の話こんな感じなんですけど
マザーを
日産からん
パッチール g せる任務左も分かりません
これからが勝負だと思っているので
まあん
今のままに待ってるまぁでも制するシッターは勢力泣ける
これからもどんどん新しいことにチャレンジして将来的には何か1つでいいから
耐えるようななアクションを自分自身でを防ぐことができたらいいなというふうに思っ
ています以上で僕の話を合わせていただきますどうもありがとうございました
[音楽]
[拍手]